I recently posted a very interesting  video to my subscription channel of Lady  sham and her client who she calls baby  sham is a transgender dominatrix her  client baby is an adult baby who did not  speak in that first interview because he  was  in his baby persona  he nodded an agreement and made some  little Grunts and moans but basically  he only communicated without words in  that first interview  so yesterday on my subscription Channel  I posted  separate interviews of Lady sham  as well as of baby where he speaks using  his words  I think these two videos will answer all  the questions that we may have had from  that first interview  you can watch that on my subscription  Channel  softwideunderbelly.com and uh  thank you for subscribing thank you for  watching  and we'll see you when we see you thanks  bye